but get some of these statistics up
nobody is working
and these are good jobs like arby's
these aren't bad jobs these are good
jobs
people aren't working at like hardee's
who doesn't want to work at hardee's
and they they complain go to minimum
wage in america right now what is
minimum wage right now
i can't believe it
minimum wage i think it's it's 7.25
cents per hour what's the pro you're
making 40
a day what's the problem do that what is
on a 40 hour work week 725 is what
you will earn
a good living 290
a week 290
a week that's almost 1200 for the month
what is that for a year if you're making
1200 for a month
you're looking at 14 15 000
that's what i thought what's the problem
out there
what's i don't get it do you get it
fifteen thousand dollars
per year because they don't understand
when they work at arby's they think it's
the end goal guys
if you play your cards right you move up
so that one day you can be the ceo of
arby's
that's the point good get the ceo of
arby's up who is this
i bet he started at orbeez
i it's paul brown
paul brown is the ceo what's his deal
let's look up paul brown
because i guarantee you this is a guy
that
started working the friars at rb's
putting the beef and chatters together
and then
he worked his way up
early career brown was previously the
president of
brands and commercial services at hilton
and the president of expedia but but
before this
he worked at orbeez i bet watch he was
also the senior
vice president of global brands at
intercontinentals
okay but he also held positions at the
boston consulting
firm and mckinsey company now mckinsey
and companies probably fast food
go to that this is probably a fast food
company
it's an american worldwide management
consulting firm oh
that advises on strategic management to
corporations governments and other
organizations
i thought it was a like a what i'm
saying is that this
is an example of someone who worked
their way up
from working at arby's
in may of 2013 brown became the ceo of
arby's
during his 10-year ceo of armies the
brand introduced a new restaurant design
and launched so we have the meat
he's the guy behind we have the meat no
who could have came up with that
listen the reason these people are
making the money they are
is because they have come up with things
that you cannot
we have the meat do you remember that
campaign of course
because we were unsure if they had the
meats but they do
and he's here saying we have the meat he
also
introduced menu items such as the
smokehouse brisket
pork belly gyros deep fried turkey and
venison
so he's not uh slacking
he's working his ass off okay
coming up with do you know how many
nights he probably laid in bed with his
wife or and or someone else
and he's laying there going how do we
communicate the idea that we have
the meats how do we do that
and and and and some hooker was probably
just like we'll just say you have the
meats and he goes
yeah we have the meats
i'm telling you right now but arby's
completed its acquisition of buffalo
wild wings for 2.9 billion in 2018.
under brown's leadership inspire
completed its acquisition of
sonic for 2.3 billion and in
2019 of october brands
uh completed its acquisition of the
sandwich chain jimmy johns
so this guy is responsible for a lot of
the fast food you eat
and he started work this is what i mean
people at arby's don't have a vision
they keep going oh my kid needs
food they don't have a vision they don't
understand like what they can do
if they believe in themselves and work
hard and hustle and grind
you can actually get to where you need
to go in this country you keep focusing
on
uh health care and i don't have clean
water but what you should be focusing on
is
what how are you positioned uniquely in
the market
to come up with something brilliant like
we have the meats
because if you're not coming up with we
have the meats what's the
point so i'm just saying we've got a
bunch of lazy
mothers and fathers trying to raise
their undeserving children
while this poor guy
paul who came up with the the idea that
we should give deep fried turkey to
people in the middle of the day
this guy has to share some of his money
oh i think not by the way
under brown's leadership fortune named
arby's to its
100 best workplaces for millennials
women and diversity
so everyone who's [ __ ]
oh our east coast we're a perfect place
to work for everyone who's [ __ ]
are you a good place to work for white
men they go like this they go
no well i'm just saying
i i i was surprised and shocked to to
know that this guy
actually didn't start making sandwiches
at arby's
i bet it's fun to work at arby's i
really do
i mean so the idea that people are
complaining
what about hearties ceo of parties let's
see
no just hardee's in general okay i want
to know what hardees is up to let's look
at hearties
see what they're up to what are they
doing
not in wikipedia i want their website
so then the a1 burger checkers just
introduced something called the monster
or something
i swear to god checkers go yeah checkers
new burger
i think it's checkers it could be
rallies or something
no the big buffer no that's been their
classic maybe it's rally it's something
i passed in florida it's called the
monster
something something i think that's
carl's jr
it might be carl's oh red robin no
no this is a fast food restaurant uh
that i passed i don't think it's that
it doesn't matter can we call arby's and
see if they're hiring right now
yeah i got mine's hooked up right now
let's call i want to call arby's
see if they're hiring and see what the
big deal is here
because i want to work and you know what
they might not even have to pay me
i just want to learn is there an
apprenticeship program where i can work
at arby's
and just learn how about that maybe stop
asking for money
like him and learn
okay i'm calling arby's let's see if
they answer i hope they do
everyone's dead they can't answer
they're probably too busy to answer
learning
about business
i mean what the [ __ ] going on here and
these are the people that want to get
paid
i'm trying to get a job
maybe we should call inspire brands and
ask for paul
are they not open no they're open right
now they have to be open it's 12 30.
it's the lunch rush
whole sonic sonic okay call sonic and
let's see
what i want to know what the starting
salary is and what's the problem
sonic is a fun place to work you get to
see fights
it's fun
none of them answer the phone
i mean good afternoon this is sonic sure
how may i help you yeah are you guys
hiring right now
we actually are sir how are you doing
good what would this like starting
salary be there
the starting salary sir we pay by the
hour but depending on the position that
you want
and then we can see about salary what
would what would it be for an hour of
work would you say
yes sir uh how much would be for an hour
work
depends what you do sir if you're a cook
you you it's
right and it'll be 11 for a cook
okay 11 for a cook what about like a
cashier
uh we what has a cashier
carbs are five dollars an hour because
they get tips oh do you get a lot of
tips
they got good amount of tips but it's
just yeah they
they have a good amount of tips so it's
under minimum wage it's five dollars an
hour and then you get tips
yes sir is it a fun place to work like
can i take some food home
for myself yeah of course okay so i
could eat every day at sonic if i wanted
to
yeah he's gotta yeah pretty much you
could have yeah you drink coffee
drink any drink you want any drink okay
so it's five dollars an hour but i could
drink all the soda i want
yeah okay and eat any food can i make
myself an ice cream every now and then
yeah of course yes sir it's not a bad
deal five an hour
tips do they really give you so they'll
give you tips and i can eat all the
uh soda and burgers i want and make
myself an ice cream
i mean you can make yourself an ice
cream and then maybe one day you'll be
able to make yourself ice cream and
another day you'll be able to
you eat some food and then the other day
i get it so you don't want to abuse it
but every now and then you could get
something different
yes sir right so you have one day's ice
cream and then the next day you can
sneak a burger
yeah and he's maybe i could sneak some
french fries on the third day
yeah okay well i appreciate it man i'll
head down there and i'll apply
yes sir but yeah uh but cooks do get
paid 11
an hour and we already need a coke so
you're need of cooks and do i have to be
good at cooking
no no sir not at all not really
do you learn you don't need any
experience for this you just
you got to be having the willingness to
learn and then and how much food can the
cooks take i would
probably a good amount uh what was that
sir
like the cooks can take a good amount of
food right
yeah we we cook about uh on the weekends
like from a thousand to two thousand
worth dollars worth of food and product
we're doing lunch and that's right
because i have a family and it's very
hard to get them food so
if i wanted to i could maybe take two
little burgers for my children
yeah so yeah i'll be fine okay yeah
cause they they're
they're one they're babies but they do
like burgers we're getting them
we're getting them started early yeah of
course
all right well thank you very much for
your time brother i appreciate it yes
sir
thank you what's the problem i mean
what is the [ __ ] problem here
you're allowed to eat
and drink all the soda you want and eat
all the uh sonic you want
i i but you got to do it in a smart way
it's like one day you make yourself the
ice cream the next day you get
and it's five an hour that
what's wrong with that it's five dollars
an hour
to work it's it now do the math on that
five dollars times four it's 800
a week right five times 40. it's 800 a
week
and then oh no it's 200 a week i'm an
idiot so then 800 a month
it's 800 a month is what i mean so 800 a
month so what's the pro
and now what is that it's under 12 grand
it's 11 grand a year
yes so but then you get the tips
but but folks you get the tips
now you know me i've got when i go to
sonic i didn't even know you could tip
or were supposed to we've gone to sonic
there's
literally nothing that would suggest
that i tip at sonic
not a sign i i don't but i imagine that
because you're making 9 600 a year but
free
you could drink anything you want any
soda you want one day you get an ice
cream next day you get french fries
not a bad deal if you were like me and
my hypothetical and i had two little
babies
they wanted burgers if i was a chef i
could bring the little burger home
to the babies again it's not a big deal
so you make 9 600 for the year now this
is fair you make 9 600 for the year but
tips
now what do you think they make in
tipster 20 000
25 000 it's sonic tips
how what do you think they're making
tips today honestly 25 bucks
a day yeah probably a day how many days
would you imagine they work
probably four four to five days so let's
say 525 is what
five times 25 would be 125. okay
and so 125 and then how many weeks let's
say
let's say they work 45 let's say they
work 50 weeks a year let's be honest
they probably work more so 50 times 125
okay that's 62.50
add it to that nine add it to the 9600
that is hey you greedy [ __ ]
that is 15 hundred and
fifty dollars a year to work
all day every day at some
but what's included in that which you're
forgetting
you greedy pigs is an occasional ice
cream and probably you could make the
large
and all the soda you want
and and occasionally you can bring a
burger home for your baby
who you should get started on liking
that burger
as early as possible so it's absurd